hey everyone I have some exciting news
from the Mongoose trainer team we are
launching a new game its tactics frenzy
and we're hoping this will help you
improve with your puzzle solving
abilities in chess this is a beta
version so we need your help to make the
game great for instance we have tried to
estimate the difficulty of the puzzles
but we're not really sure if we got it
right there for your help in doing the
puzzles and giving us an idea of how
difficult they are is super valuable now
during the course of the next couple of
weeks we will be adding new feature
making improvements and hopefully with
your feedback making this the greatest
test tool on the Internet
where we're going to actually try
tracking let's let's give it a go so we
have a tactic here I'm probably supposed
to be checkmating blacks King yes Queen
takes page six and then Brooke g7 if the
King had taken back I would have had
book age for checkmate what's going on
here we have a check another check mmm
but this is where it gets tricky check
the king is forced out on the open board
and we gonna solve your health is very
very much appreciated and we hope that
we're gonna make this your favorite tool
on the Internet